boris becker deutsche tennislegende und
ein verurteilter straftäter muss ins
gefängnis um 16 uhr 46 deutscher zeit
verkündete richterin deborah taylor in
london das strafmaß zweieinhalb jahre
die hälfte dieser zeit muss er hinter
gittern absitzen noch am abend wurde er
direkt vom gerichtsgelände mit einem
gefangenen transporter in den knast
gebracht keine letzte umarmung mit
seiner freundin lillian oder seinem sohn
nur im gerichtssaal kein letzter kurs in
diesem weißen transporter wurde er ins
gefängnis gebracht johnny cash und ich
werden gleich mit beckers tochter anna
ermakova über diesen dramatischen tag
sprechen aber janina lasst uns zuerst zu
unserem reporter john puthenpurackal in
london gehen der im gerichtssaal dabei
war in diesen dramatischen moment als
die richterin das strafmaß verkündete
jon m uns nochmal mit zu diesem moment
da ist so hoch dramatisch als um 1645
richterin deborah taylor verkündete dass
boris becker für zwei jahre und sechs
monate ins gefängnis soll sie erklärte
dann noch mal dass es die hälfte der
haftstrafe sein soll die ihrem gefängnis
verbringt und sie andere also die andere
hälfte auf bewährung und boris becker
nahm regungslos das urteil zur kenntnis
setzte sich dann mit hochrotem kopf auf
den stuhl band sich die schuhe zu nahm
dann seine grüne tasche und verließ dann
über den seitenausgang des glaskasten
dem gericht sein englischer kollege
sagte mir noch das kurz vorm verlassen
ihm seine partnerin lilly an einen
luftkuss zugeworfen haben soll ansonsten
blieb keine zeit zur verabschiedung es
ging ganz ganz schnell ist auch hoch
dramatisch
thomas hat es gerade schon angekündigt
und wir haben sie gerade auch einmal
ganz kurz schon im bild gesehen wir
sprechen gleich live mit anna emma
koffer mit boris tochter aber lasst uns
erst noch mal über die anderen kinder
sprechen wenn eines dieser kinder boris
ältester sohn war heute im gericht dabei
genau wie eine freundin lillian sie ist
mitte dreißig sie jedes jahr fast 20
jahre jünger als boris und die beiden
haben das drama in diesem gerichtssaal
verfolgt heute beschreibt doch einmal
wie die beiden auf dich gewirkt haben
wie gab es dann noch eine abschiedsszene
wir haben die beiden reagiert gab es
tränen gab es zusammenbrüche nehmen uns
einmal mit in diesem saal
ja es war sehr herzlich und libyen und
nur der älteste sohn saßen und bäcker
aus gesehen auf dem rechten flügel des
gerichts und als dann nur teilweise
strafmaß verkündung war konnte ich sie
lilly and leicht die hand und nur
anfangs also in händen hielt beide
hielten in diesem moment zusammen
drückten die daumen aber es war alles
vergebens trend boris becker wurde zu
einer gefängnisstrafe verurteilt und als
dann das urteil fest stand habe ich nur
gesehen wie reagieren anfängt zu weinen
sie hatte tränen in den augen und
mitarbeiter als auch angehörige kam zu
ihr verdeckten dann die sich zu ihr weil
der ganze saal war ja voller
journalisten es war herzzerreißend und
man hat gesehen da wird gerade eine
familie getrennt denn mit diesem urteil
glaube ich hatten alle nicht gerechnet
und es dürfte noch nicht mal mehr eine
umarmung geben kein letzter kurs kein
letztes goodbye wie man sagen würde
man das britische gesetz ist in diesem
kontext sehr sehr hart werden bei einer
gefängnisstrafe wird der verurteilte
direkt aus dem anklage kasten die in
einen sicherheitsbereich gebracht in
begleitung eines mitarbeiters ich denke
die große verabschiedung die fand
gestern statt hier sehen wir ein foto
oder jüngste sohn von boris becker
amadeus deinem vater war besucht er ein
kuss auf den kopf bekommt kurz zuvor kam
sein ältester sohn noah und gestern
glaube ich fand die große verabschiedung
statt in anführungsstrichen der letzte
tag vor der ungewissheit wieder zurück
kommt oder nicht bevor wir mit anna
ermakova sprechen beschreibt uns doch
noch mal was jetzt auf boris zukommt wir
haben gesehen wie er in diesen erweisen
gefangenen transporter
aus dem gerichtsgebäude gefahren wurde
du hast in dem moment direkt daneben
gestanden
wie wird das jetzt im gefängnis für ihn
sein wo er ja heute schon die erste
nacht verbringen muss
ja ist es die größte niederlage in der
karriere von boris becker als wird eine
ganz schwierige nacht ist wird eine ganz
schwere zeit und ich habe boris becker
vergangenen wochen im monat miterlebt
und habe gesehen wie er vor allem in den
vergangenen tagen immer mehr abgebaut
hat und ich habe die große befürchtung
dass nur möglich dieses gefängnis diese
gefängnisstrafe dass er daran zerbrechen
könnte ja nach unserer information wird
er nun im zentralgefängnis race world
dem zweitgrößten gefängnis von dort im
nordosten
aufbewahrt sozusagen er das ist seine
neue städte das gilt wohl als
übergangsstation bevor er weiter verlegt
wird aber man's world das ist ein
gefängnis schaut schaut es jedem ihr in
london denn dass das ein gefängnis wo
sexualstraftäter ihren eigenen traktor
verbrecher mit hohen strafen sitzen und
mittendrin boris becker der einst in
deutschland geschichte geschrieben hat
er muss jetzt in einer zelle man spricht
von sieben bis acht quadratmetern
gegebenenfalls mit einem anderen
gefangenen sitzen denn dieses gefängnis
camp keinen promi-bonus und wir haben
gerade diesen garten gesehen das steht
für die historie die härte dieses
gefängnis denn im neunzehnten
jahrhundert wurden dort todesstrafe
verrichtet wird sodann heute nicht mehr
am boden bleibt bitte in der leitungen
vielen dank und jetzt wollen wir
exklusive sprechen mit anna ermakova der
tochter von boris becker die uns jetzt
live zugeschaltet ist guten namen franco
war
guten abend beim akw sekunden mithören
was unser reporter gerade erzählt hat
wie fühlen sie sich nach dieser
nachricht dass ihr vater ins gefängnis
muss jetzt schon im gefängnis ist
ich stehe unter schock
über die tatsache dass er das eineinhalb
jahre ins gefängnis
sie versucht zu helfen wie ich kann mich
ans gericht geschrieben um klarzustellen
dass man sein bruder mein halbbruder
matthäus s 12 as und ich heute
klarstellen dass ich mich um ihn sorge
vaterfigur fehlen und jetzt ist ja eine
essentielle zeit im leben eines jungen
menschen für
sie seien gerade diese minuten
ich möchte eigentlich auch gar nicht
vorstellen sie haben gerade ihren
kleinen bruder angesprochen amadeus erst
zwölf jahre alt sie sagten sie machen
sich sorgen um ihnen haben auch an das
gericht einen brief geschrieben
mal abgesehen davon dass ihm jetzt die
vaterfigur fehlen wird für eine sehr
lange zeit und ein jahr und drei monate
sind wahnsinnig lang für einen
zwölfjährigen jungen worüber machen sie
sich noch sorgen in bezug auf ihren
kleinen bruder
hier ist einfach nicht fair dass er es
jetzt durchmachen muss für ihn wird es
besonders schwer
er ist einfach erst 13 jahre als in
england beginnt jetzt an der neuen
schule lernt neue leute kennen und das
allein ist schon super schwer und ohne
eine vaterfigur all diesen stress presse
hat das große interesse wird es wirklich
besonders schwer für ihn jeder kennt
solche schwierigen zeiten im leben oder
und das ist wirklich schwer besonders
für einen jungen menschen
hatten sie gelegenheit mit ihren brüdern
zu sprechen auch elias und nur
tatsächlich ist es so dass ich gerade
vorhin erst aufgelegt habe nach dem
leben das urteil verkündet wurde weil
wir einfach gemeinsam unter schock
stehen ja
eher schock ist das richtige wort sogar
wir waren hier kurzer zeit auch in
schockstarre weil wir es nicht glauben
konnten aber es ist leider die realität
wie sieht es aus wann haben sie ihren
vater denn eigentlich das letzte mal
gesehen wann haben sie das letzte mal
kontakt mit ihrem vater und planen sie
dann auch ihnen möglicherweise dann im
gefängnis zu besuchen
naja obwohl ich ihnen seit langem ich
gesehen habe habe ich ja versucht ihn
per telefon so gut zu unterstützen wie
ich
wünsche ihr nur das beste und ich hoffe
so sehr dass der starke sein dieser
schweren zeit seines lebens und
natürlich werde ich ihn unterstützen und
auch besucher persönlich und da mein
bestes geben wirklich ich hoffe dass das
die zeit für ihn dort im gefängnis ein
bisschen leichter macht zumindest denn
dass es wirklich eine sehr schwere zeit
vielen dank frau ermakova für dieses
gespräch
danke ihnen ich wollte einfach nur sagen
dass ich ihn unterstütze
vielen dank und
wir gehen noch mal nach london zu
unserem reporter john kucera ka dieser
tag war ja nicht nur dramatisch in
diesem moment vielleicht kann man sich
wiedersehen da bist du nicht nur in
diesem moment um 16 uhr 46 als das
urteil verkündet wurde sondern der ganze
vormittag ja bereits dort im
gerichtssaal und dann gab es eine
mittagspause und man musste also noch
mal wieder länger warten boris becker
musste warten wie dieses urteil jetzt
ausfallen würde beschreibt uns nochmal
auch diesen vormittag den ganzen tag
dort im gericht
ja dieser tag der lief eigentlich ab wie
ein film ich erinnere mich noch an den
auftritt als boris becker gegen
gegen 12 uhr deutscher zeit
dort als sie gegen 13 uhr deutscher zeit
dort am gericht auftauchte er wirkte gut
gelaunt adrett gekleidet haare perfekt
geschnitten seine partnerin elia
das gleiche outfit beide kamen hand in
hand er lächelte sie an und er wollte
der welt zeigen beide wollten der welt
zeigen wir lassen uns nichts anhaben die
hautfarbe passt und wir werden das
zusammen durchstehen danach ging ja um
13 uhr britischer zeit das erfahrt los
und wie du schon gesagt hat dieses
verfahren finden erst mal so anders
natürlich anklage und verteidigung ihre
argumente vorgebracht haben warum eine
gefängnisstrafe in ihren augen richtig
ist oder in ebene oder in augen der
verteidigung eine bewährungsstrafe
besser für becker sei und dann gab es
eine mittagspause und nach der
mittagspause da überschlugen sich für
mich eine echte ereignisse denn boris
becker wurde kurz vor beginn der
verhandlung in den saal hinein gelassen
er ging in den glaskasten setzte sich
auf sein stuhl knöpft er sich vorher
nochmals ein jackett zu und dann schaute
er stark auf den richterstuhl und
wartete auf die richterin und wartete
und wartete und die nicht lange auf sich
warten nämlich fast 20 minuten weil das
war eine unerträgliche situation denn
mit der zeit bringen die zuschauer um
ihn herum an zu lachen verbreiteten gute
laune flachsen versichern während becker
mit hochroten kopf mit gefalteten händen
dort saß und ich glaube auch er nicht
mal die welt verstand was gerade um ihn
herum passiert er fürchtet sich um seine
freiheit während um ihn herum einfach
einschreiben im stattfand und dann kam
die richterin nach 20 minuten rein jeder
dachte irgendwas muss passiert sein aber
sie hat sich gründlich überlegt und hat
dann ihr urteil gesprochen schon jetzt
gibt es noch eine möglichkeit für ihn in
revision zu denen ganz kurze antwort von
dir noch einmal was sagen die experten
wird er das in betracht ziehen
davon ist erst mal nicht auszugehen ich
meine ein
urteil da wirklich einspruch einzulegen
oder noch eine revision zu gehen da
müsste schon ein überzogen des urteils
ein hund ist kurz zu sagen die richterin
hat gesagt ich meinen es gut mit ihm ich
konnte ihn für jeden der vier
strafpunkte 18 monate geben aber ich
erkenne an dass sie in gewissen punkten
auch menschlich waren oder guten willen
versucht haben zu zeigen aber am ende
als sie ihn dafür bestraft dass er aus
seinen fehlern nicht gelernt hat dann ja
sie sprach immer von dem charakter der
grundcharakter im britischen heißt dass
man sich einmalig bei in der
vergangenheit verhalten hat das hat ja
bekanntlich nicht getan wurde 2002 wegen
steuerhinterziehung verurteilt und aus
diesem urteil hat er in den augen der
richterin nicht geleert john kucera ka
live aus london wo boris becker die
deutsche tennislegende und muss man dazu
sagen ein verurteilter straftäter heute
zu zweieinhalb jahren gefängnis
verurteilt worden ist vielen dank
tja und er wird schon heute nacht im
gefängnis schlafen giannina letzter satz
von dir er ist hoch geflogen erst hoch
geflogen und er ist ganz ganz tief
abgestürzt und jetzt ganz heftig auf
geknallt und das tut richtig weh und das
tut allen fans und zwar in dem ort an
dem er seine größten triumph gehabt hat
in wimbledon jetzt seine größte
niederlage in london von uns aus was das
für den moment aktuelle informationen
wie immer bei bild.de schöne am noch für
sie